- [Instructor] In this video,
we're going to dig a little
bit deeper into the notion
of perfectly competitive markets.
So we're gonna think about
under what scenarios a firm
would make an economic profit
or an economic loss in them.
Now as a reminder, these
perfectly competitive markets
are something of a theoretical ideal.
There's few markets in the real world
that are truly perfectly competitive.
Some might get close,
but most markets are
someplace in a spectrum
between perfectly competitive
and, at the other extreme,
say, something like a monopoly.
But here we're talking
about perfect competition.
And perfect competition,
the firm's products aren't differentiated.
There's no barriers to entry or exit.
And so in that situation,
the market supply and demand curves
are going to define the
price in the market,
which are also going to define
the marginal revenue for these firms.
They're all going to be price-takers.
They're going to be
passive in terms of price.
Whatever the market price
is, that's the price
that they are going to
sell their products for.
And their decision is
really what quantity does,
to produce and sell and whether
to enter or exit the market.
So let's look at that a little bit.
So these are just your classic
and supply, demand curve,
supply and demand curves
you might see for a market.
The first few units in the market,
there's a huge marginal benefit,
so people are willing to pay a lot.
But then each incremental unit,
the marginal benefit's a
little bit lower and lower
and lower and lower, and
that's why we have those,
that downward-sloping demand curve.
And then on the supply
curve, the first unit
in the market might be fairly
inexpensive to produce,
but then the marginal cost gets higher
and higher and higher.
And where they meet,
where the supply and demand meet,
that tells us the equilibrium price
and equilibrium quantity in the market.
And we can show that with that line,
and let's just say that
equilibrium price is $10.
And as I just mentioned,
that's going to have to be the
price that all of the firms,
and these might not be all
of the firms in the market,
but all of the firms in the market,
if we're talking about a
perfectly competitive market,
would just have to take that price.
So given that,
what quantity would firms
A, B, and C produce?
And which of these firms
would be profitable or not>
I encourage you to pause the video
and think about those two questions.
If you could just answer,
which of these firms would
be profitable or not?
And we're talking about
economic profit in this context.
All right, well let's
look at firm A first.
Well, firm A, for any of them,
it is not rational to produce a quantity
where the marginal cost is higher
than the marginal revenue
that the firm's getting.
And remember, this line right over here,
this line right here, which is
the price line, that's also,
that is price, which is
equal to marginal revenue.
And so for that extra unit,
if you can't sell it for
more than you're producing,
then you wouldn't produce that extra unit.
So it's rational for them to
produce more and more and more.
The marginal cost goes higher and higher
until right at the
point that marginal cost
is equal to marginal revenue,
which is equal to price,
the market price, which
they're just going to take.
So it's rational for this firm
to produce this quantity right over here.
So I'll just go quantity,
I'll say quantity for that firm.
Now is this firm going
to be profitable or not?
Well, at this quantity,
what's its average total cost?
Well, its average total
cost is right over there.
And so for every unit,
it's going to make this difference
between the price or the
marginal revenue it's getting
and its average total cost.
And so one way to think about
the profit of this firm is,
and we're talking about economic profit,
it's going to be the area of
this rectangle right over here.
So let's say if the average
total cost at that quantity is,
let's say that this is $8,
then this height of the
rectangle is 10 minus eight.
The height right over here,
let me do this in a different color,
this height right over here is $2.
And then the width is going to
be the quantity of that firm.
And so let's say the
quantity of that firm,
let's say it's 10,000 units a year,
10,000,
10,000 units per year.
And so the area right over
here would be $2 times 10,000.
It would be $20,000,
$20,000 per time unit,
per time unit if we're talking
all of this as, say, per year.
Now let's go to firm B.
Using that same analysis,
is firm B making an economic profit
or is it not making an economic profit?
Well, firm B is once again
going to be a price-taker.
And so the price right over here,
the equilibrium price in the market,
is going to be equal to the price
that that firm has to take,
which is going to be its
marginal revenue curve.
And that's why it's a flat
Because no matter what
quantity they produce,
they're gonna get that same price.
And it wouldn't be rational
for them to produce a quantity
where marginal cost is
higher than marginal revenue,
and so they would
produce right over there.
Now what is their economic
profit at this quantity?
So this is quantity of
the second firm, firm B.
I'll write it like that.
Maybe that is firm A.
And maybe this is also, eh,
it looks about the same.
I'll make 'em a little bit different.
Let's say that's 9,500
units per time period.
Well, here the average total cost
at that quantity is equal
to the marginal cost,
so which is equal to the marginal revenue.
So at that quantity,
whatever, that $10
they're getting per unit,
they're also spending
on average $10 per unit.
Another way to think about it,
the area of that rectangle
is going to be zero
because it has no height.
So this, this situation right over here,
the firm has zero,
zero economic,
I'll write $0 of economic profit.
And then last but not least,
let's think about firm C.
Pause this video, and think about
what its economic profit would be.
Well, like we've seen,
it would be rational for
it to produce the quantity
where marginal cost is
equal to marginal revenue,
which is equal to the market price.
So it would produce this
quantity right over here.
And let's say that that
quantity is 9,000 units.
And what's its average total cost then?
So at 9,000 units, its average total cost,
let's say that that is
$12 right over there.
So what's its economic profit?
So for every unit it's selling,
it's getting $10 and it's costing
$12 on average to produce it.
So it's taking an economic
loss of $2 per unit.
So $2 per unit, so this
height right over here is $2,
times the units, times 9,000,
you're going to have two times 9,000,
you're going to have an $18,000
not economic profit but economic,
economic loss.
Now one thing to think about is
why would any firm be in this situation?
Well, it's important to think about things
in the short run versus the long run.
In the short run,
we've talked about this
analysis right over here,
where a firm can decide what
quantity it would produce
that is rational.
Its fixed costs are
fixed in the short run.
We've studied that in multiple videos.
But in the long run, its
fixed costs aren't fixed,
and so the firm could decide
to enter or exit the market.
And so for firm C,
while they've already
put in those fixed costs,
it is actually rational for them to do it
because they're actually
able to make their,
the marginal revenue they
get up to that quantity,
it's at least,
they're able to more than
cover their marginal costs.
And then they're able to eat
up or I guess you could say
take care of some of their fixed costs,
But they're still not able
to run an economic profit.
So in the long run,
it wouldn't be rational for
this firm to stay in the market.
They would likely exit the market.